Minecraft plus Animal Crossing gleich
Coral Island und dieses Spiel spielen
wir
heute
oh eine Möwe und Boot das bin ich
übrigens hier auf dem Boot und wer das
ist keine Ahnung wahrscheinlich der
[Musik]
Captain h sind auf der Insel angekommen
hallo Luca willkommen auf Coral Island
deem neuen zu Hause
oh
das ist mein neues Zuhause ich habe wer
ist er denn Joko ne Joko Winterscheid
hallo Lua es ist immer aufregend ein
neues Gesicht auf unserer kleinen Insel
willkommen zu heißen das übrigens
dinder keine Ahnung was das für ein Name
ist wie du siehst freuen sich die
Menschen hier sehr dass du hier bist und
das hier ist anscheinend mein Feld was
er mir gerade
zeigt wo ich Sachen anpflanzen kann ist
allerdings ein bisschen rumpelzeugs da
drauf geh jetzt hab Erdbeben ach du
heilige Scheiße es sieht zwar ein wenig
chaotisch aus aber du wirst dich
bestimmt bald darum kümmern ja dicker
wenn das nicht so groß wä wie Zeh
Fußballfelder das hier ist unsere
lieferkiste der Bürgermeister Conor der
uns am Schiff abgeholt hat hat mir
gerade gesagt dass immer wenn ich eine
Ernte habe ich das einfach in die
lieferkiste schmeißen kann und dann
kriege ich halt einfach Geld zurück oh
du hast eine Gießkanne eine Axt eine
Sense und ein paar zufällige Samen
erhalten be Minecraft kriegt man das
nicht man einfach ohne alles der
Bürgermeister Connor wint Haut ab und
geht das Bild fadet aus und ach du grüne
neun das ist ja ein ein Animal Crossing
mit Minecraft dieses Haus ist ein anim
crossing mit dem schwarz aus rum und das
hier das ist ja ein Minecraft nur läuft
man halt ein bisschen eckiger als bei
Minecraft und crossing gehen nach
draußen und haben post was ist denn hier
postlesen Luca damit wir dein Haus
repieren können musst du Material für
uns bitte sammle 50 hol und 20 Stein das
sollte reichen und wir haben auch noch
unsere anfangsaufgaben die da lauten Z
Samenpflanzen und diese z Samen dann
auch noch Gießen also zusammengefasst
Freunde das hier ist unser Haus wir sind
gerade auf Coral Island angekommen und
haben hier unser riesiges Feld wir haben
schon einige Geschenke hier unten
bekommen und ich würde jetzt einfach mal
die Spitzhacke wählen um hier ach guck
mal so einfach geht
das ach
lachkick kann ich jetzt auch von hier
den
jo
ah weit geht nicht aber das ist
entspannt wir müssen quasi nicht immer
die ganze Zeit davor stehen so wie in
Minecraft sondern wir können das auch
aus einer leichten Entfernung machen
können jetzt hier auch die Bäume fällen
mit der Axt obviously dann haben wir
wahrscheinlich auch noch auf der fünf
die Sense die dann für etwas höheres
Gras denke ich mal ist wie
hier ja oder hier
vorne
nee ach da brauchen wir
ah ach so das muss ich dann wiederum
loslassen wenn ich das nur gedrückt
halte holt er nur aus dann macht er
einal komplett rum und wenn ich nur so
mache dann macht er nur ein klein Bich
okay niedrige Ausdauer du kannst essen
oder trinken um eine Ausdauer wieder
aufzufüllen rüste Nahrung oder ein
Getränk aus und drücke dann linke
Maustaste um es zu verziehren du kannst
auch zu Bett gehen um deine Ausdauer
wieder aufzufüllen ach ja wir sehen
schon ich habe 18 von 450 Ausdauer nur
noch aber ich habe schon 41 Holz
gesammelt so oder so haben wir glaube
ich nichts zu essen deswegen würde ich
sagen gehen wir jetzt erstmal nach Hause
und legen uns in unser Bettchen rein geh
zu
Bett der erste Tag ist vorbei im
Frühling im ersten Jahr okay das Spiel
ist anscheinend sogar darauf ausgelegt
dass man das ein bisschen länger spielt
wir speichern das ganze jetzt ist
gespeichert wir sind wieder wach und
haben eine volle Ausdauer ich liebe
solche Spiele ihr wisst das ja auch ich
bin bei Minecraft nie so einer der jetzt
sagt komm ich gehe jetzt in die Hölle
ich gehe Strip mein und hol mir netherri
wir haben Post wer schreibt uns den
heute neuer Gegenstand wir präsentieren
die basistasche sie verfügt insgesamt
über 20 Unterteilungen das sind fünf
mehr okay wir haben größeren Beutel auch
wie bei Animal Crossing sehr wild es ist
6 Uhr 10 Uhr morgens die Sonne geht
geradeaus komm wir gehen mal kurz ans
Meer generell können wir ja mal unsere
Stadt so ein bisschen entdecken hier
schön über die Brücke rüber hier unten
laufen wir jetzt mal lang wir haben hier
vorne einen kleinen Fluss da vor was ist
denn
[Musik]
das ist es okay never mind das war
anscheinend irgendwie eine Raupe oder so
guck mal hier mit dem Steinweg rüber
hier eine Ecke da sind irgendwie Sitze
können wir uns h
hinsetzen ich will jetzt nicht die Bank
Abfällen laufen wir mal hier runter
oh nein Pack doch mal die Axt Weg Luca
ich will mit dir reden
Valentina hallo Mr Luca schön Dich
kennenzulernen okay
tschüss okay das war's dann auch hier
vorne links haben wir anscheinend so ein
kleines Restaurant das waren auf jeden
Fall überall hier so ein paar Sitzplätze
hier kann man tauchen gehen also gibt's
anscheinend irgendwelche Tiere hier
vorne sind Bote wir haben hier sind wir
angekommen das meh ach
[Musik]
du so meine das muss ich kurz Kollegen
schicken e Bro ja ich nehme gerade ein
Youtube Video auf wo ich auf so einer
Insel bin schau mal wie das Boot
aussieht so oder so würde ich allerdings
sagen dass wir wieder zurück zu unserer
kleinen Farm
[Musik]
laufen und da sind wir auch schon wieder
wir haben die noch in der Hand damit
wollten wir ja gerade eigentlich noch
Valentina tothauen sammel jetzt
allerdings erstmal noch so ein bisschen
Holz ein bei diesen Bäumen muss man
immer so ein bisschen doller gegen
kloppen ist natürlich auch logisch das
dauert ein Tick länger als Steine obwohl
eigentlich würde ich denken dass man
solche Bäume trotzdem schneller abfällt
als Steine weil ich meine schaut euch
das mal an bei so einem Stein hau ich
dreimal drauf ne zweimal sogar nur dann
ist er weg und bei so ein Baum musste
ich ja vorhin locker zehn mal drauf
haauen diind kleinen geht's dann
wiederum bisschen schneller einfach
einmal zack zack hier muss man wieder
die Sense in die Hand nehmen hier so
drüber das Spiel ist übrigens das ist
hier nicht bezahlt oder so ne nicht dass
ihr denkt weil man das Spiel nicht kennt
ey Luca kriegt dafür Geld dass er da
spielt ich habe das auch ganz normal
gekauft Kost 30 € ich fand es nur
unfassbar schön Holz ist schon weg wir
müssen noch sieben Steine sammeln hier
vorne huen wir noch mal eben den Stein
weg hier machen mal den Stein weg zack
zack zack dann haben wir hier noch mal
Steine wir brauchen nur noch vier Stück
ich möchte mich auch eigentlich eher
darauf konzentrieren dass wir hier vorne
vielleicht so ein bisschen die Steine
wegmachen weil ich eigentlich mich so
ein bisschen Vorarbeiten möchte ich
möchte hier erstmal mit der Farm starten
weil ja besonders der Bereich den wir
wenn wir mal die Karte aufrufen hier
hinten haben für uns ja noch komplett
ungenutzt sein wird weil da müssen wir
uns ja hier komplett überall
durcharbeiten deswegen würde ich sagen
wir machen jetzt erstmal hier vorne was
ist denn das du kannst das mit deinem
aktuellen Werkzeug nicht kaputt machen
was ist den das für ein Monsterbaum ich
würde allerdings sagen dass wir jetzt
hier vorne noch mal eben den Stein
abbauen sodass wir das alles fertig
haben besuche den
ist doch safe irgendwo hier in der Stadt
oder Stadtbewohner
Valentina fremder fremder Haus von Jack
Kira und Kenny oh mein Gott wir müssen
noch so viele Leute kennenlernen dann
suchen wir mal den
Schreiner wird sich wahrscheinlich nur
um Stunden handeln ach der Schreiner der
Jumbo der testet wahrscheinlich gerade
Schnitzel im chinach guck mal Kinder hi
Arch bist du wirklich die neue Person ja
Hunde ar Schnauze geh mal weg wie kann
ich das Überspringen so guck mal wir
haben Hunde und die laufen vor mir weg
und was ist das ich kann mit einem
batagam reden lind sieht heute glücklich
aus aber gut Freunde das ist anscheinend
die Stadt wir haben hier vorne ein
Museum wir haben hier schöne
gepflasterte Wege hier ist eine
traubenfarm also anscheinend ein Weingut
oder irgendwie sowas guck mal hier sind
auch überall so weinfessser stehen
überall so ein paar Pilze ach die können
wir ernten Inventar nee ich habe noch
einiges an Platz im Rucksack ist egal
wir haben so viel zu tun wir müssen auf
jeden Fall erstm den Schreiner finden
hier haben wir irgendwelche
interessanten Gebäude hier vorne ich
fühle mich ein bisschen wie bei
hawksksmeet in Harry Potter ich glaube
allerdings das vorne sieh aus wie so ein
Zauberwald ich glaube wir laufen erstmal
wieder hier links runter weil wir uns
hier eher wieder in Richtung guck mal
sind das jetzt hier Breaking Bad tut mir
leid wir haben heute geschlossen okay es
gibt anscheinend noch einiges auf das
wir noch gar nicht zugreifen können weil
wir gerade erst im Spiel angekommen sind
und wir zu früh einfach hier in den
ganzen Ecken unterwegs sind aber ich
lieb es einfach zu entdecken guck mal
hier vorne auch mit den Wasserfällen
sehr sehr schön hier vorne steht dass es
zur Farm nach unten geht können wir auch
hier Sachen abbauen
jo e das ist ja so wild wir können alles
verändern also es ist quasi wirklich wie
eine Mischung aus Minecraft und Animal
Crossing hier unten geht's lang aber wo
ist denn jetzt die Schreinerei ist auch
schon 18 Uhr wir müssten mal langsam
wieder schlafen gehen vielleicht vorne
sind Hühner
undten Fasan die gehen alle in ihren
Stall rein hier vorne kann ich nicht
lang hier sind irgendwie ach das sind
Wasserfelder wahrscheinlich wird der
Reis angebaut oder so hier geht's wieder
raus vorne kann ich noch lang laufen
jetzt bin ich glaube ich wieder an
meiner Farm ja hier ist mein Haus jetzt
bin ich einmal im Kreis gelaufen ich
würde allerdings sagen dass ich jetzt
auch noch mal eben fix schlafen gehe
jetzt müssen wir auch noch schöner
machen ne das hier geht ja gar nicht
auch die Tapete hier der Boden ist
kaputt kann ich hier auch irgendwas
fahmäßiges machen ne hier drin geht's
nicht wir gehen
schlafen Tag 2 ist zu Ende wir haben
noch immer kein
Einkommen weil wir nichts verdient haben
weil wir noch nichts angepflanzt haben
aber das wird als nächstes passieren wir
gehen raus und es regnet oh nein wir
haben Pitzen überall aber das ist sehr
gut für unsere Farm vielleicht sollten
wir den Moment nutzen um jetzt hier vor
alles so ein bisschen dem Erdboden
gleich zu machen also ich meine gut das
ist ja Erdboden ist ja schon auf einer
Höhe Pflanzen wir steckerüben oder
Gänseblümchen an da wir so ein bisschen
natürlich ans Essen denken müssen würde
ich sagen eher Steckrüben die soll man
im Frühjahr Pflanzen die wachsen in vier
Tagen und die erzeugen regelmäßige
Qualität das sagt mir alles gar nichts
aber ich pflanze s hier einfach mal hin
zack zack zack zack zack zack neun Stück
haben wir gepflanzt das heißt wir müssen
eh noch ein bisschen Gänseblümchen
Pflanzen die Frage ist jetzt allerdings
wie ich das Aufbau da bin ich jetzt
gerade so ein bisschen überfragt wie ich
das ma WIS ich möchte jetzt nicht hier
Gänseblümchen mit dransetzen aber komm
dann machen wir halt wir machen ein Feld
hier vorne jetzt ganz allein machen wir
hier ein Gänseblümchen würde ich sagen n
damit wir jetzt erstmal die Quest fertig
haben seht ihr schon Zeh Samen sind
gepflanzt die müssen wir jetzt noch
Gießen es regnet zwar aber ich muss es
wohl trotzdem gießen gut ne
h wieso geht das hier nicht hoch ich
habe doch das gegossen oder muss ich gar
kein Blümchen anpflanzen V laufen wir
mal rüber zu den Steckrüben treten
natürlich nicht drauf und gießen die
jetzt passiert auch nichts also meine
Anzeige hier oben geht runter aber
samenießen geht nicht hoch meine
Gießkanne geht allerdings leer wieso
kann ich denn die Samen nicht gießen ich
pflanz mal noch mal die wilden Samen an
das mache ich jetzt mal hier
beispielsweise zack zack zack wilde
Samen Wille Samen Wille Samen wir nehmen
die Gießkanne Gießen Gießen Gießen es
geht nicht hoch
[Musik]
h g kann es leer gehe zu einem Teich
oder einem Brunnen auf deiner Farm und
de giekanne aufzufüllen das heißt ich
fül die giekanne mit Wasser auf und
jetzt haben wir aber das geht nicht hoch
was mache ich denn falsch vielleicht
soll wirklich erstmal zum Schreiner
[Musik]
gehen
ist das der
Schreiner du solltest nicht hineingehen
du weißt nicht W ein Zimmer das ist okay
anscheinend ist es dann nicht der
Schreiner hier darf ich auch nicht rein
aber sieht unnormal schön aus e wenn wir
irgendwann unser Haus auch so schön
machen könnten das wä schon krass ich
weiß J doch trotzdem nicht wo ich jetzt
den Schreiner so wirklich finde so ich
bin jetzt einfach mal hier reingegangen
weil das im im Wald hier war guck mal
das sieht auch voll schön aus hier bei
denen ne haben die schon alles
angepflanzt aber ich habe ja auch schon
was angepflanzt aber es halt noch nicht
gewachsen und Gießen bringt auch nichts
kann ich das hier wegmachen irgendwie
nee hier ist eine Kuh drauf abgebildet
das heißt wird auch nicht der Schreiner
sein Schreiner oh mein Gott wir haben es
ist direkt hier neben oh lol wir hätten
einfach auf der Karte mit der Maus
drüber scrollen können in dem Haus von
Joko Dinda und Archi dann müsste das das
hier sein ja schaut mal hier liegt auch
schon voll viel Holz Carpenter nee
Carpenter ist Carpenter nicht irgendwas
mit Teppich sieht aber schon sehr nach
Schreinerei Quest aktualisiert repariere
dein Haus okay sehr nice dann kaufe ich
jetzt mal ein was kann ich für dich tun
Schreiner was für Hühnerstall ich soll
euch das bringen für mein Haus pariere
dein Haus ja was soll ich denn da machen
ich glaube ich muss einfach wieder
zurücklaufen guck mal hier vorne wird
sogar richtig gearbeitet ne
mit seiner Maschine jetzt läuft er hier
rüber schnappt sich von da seine
Sachen simmt der Lein oder irgendwie so
ne eine Bohrmaschine ist das glaube ich
ne und bohrt jetzt in seinem Tisch rum
das Spiel hat schon eine krasse Liebe
zum Detail aber gut okay dadurch dass
ich hier war und diese Meldung ja kam
heißt das ja dass ich jetzt wirklich nur
noch zurückgehen muss und mein Haus
wirklich reparieren muss und laufen wir
jetzt den gleichen Weg wieder zurück und
schauen mal ich habe auch gerade gerade
mal in
den questeinstellungen geschaut wie wir
das mit den samengießen machen sollen
und da stand einfach dass wir
tatsächlich schlicht und ergreifend
jeden Tag gießen müssen wir Steppen
zurück zu unserem Haus und checken mal
ab was wir jetzt hier reparieren können
schaut mal hier vorne ist unser Zaun
noch ein bisschen kaputt müssen wir
einfach allgemein noch so ein bisschen
hier was dran werkeln und tun jetzt sind
wir hier wie können wir das ganze jetzt
reparieren
ich stehe ein bisschen auf dem Schlauch
ich habe aber auch noch die ganzen
Materialien vielleicht muss ich doch
noch mal zum Schreiner Leute wie ist bei
euch hoffe super da bin ich wieder hier
ist der Schreiner ich rede mal mit dem
Joko wow du bist ja unterwegs ich glaube
ich bleibe heute drin du weißt schon
wegen des Regens okay also der hat
anscheinend nichts zu melden dann laufen
wir mal rüber zu Dinda hieß ja glaube
ich ist gerade am Putzen alles in
Ordnung keine legs hoffe ich nö alles in
Ordnung ist H ansonsten noch jemand
vielleicht der Bürgermeister oder so
aber ist wahrscheinlich in seinem
Bürgermeisterhaus du stehst Arch nicht
nah genug um dieses Zimmer betreten zu
können das heißt wir müssen richtige
Bindungen aufbauen aber gut die
Schreiner sollen anscheinend mein Haus
reparieren dann würde ich mich doch mal
kurz hier
hinstellen jetzt jetzt Fäll hier nicht
den Tisch ab Lua sorry wir sind derzeit
geschlossen offen von 9R bis 17 Uhr wie
spät ist es denn
17:10 das ist hundertprozentig eine
deutsche Insel da die Leute da vorne
natürlich normale Arbeitszeiten haben
und pünktlich auf und zu machen würde
ich sagen gehen wir an der Stelle noch
mal ganz kurz schlafen schauen uns die
Zusammenfassung des dritten Tages an wir
werden auch hier kein bisschen Gewinn
gemacht haben alles in Ordnung Spiel
wird gespeichert wir stehen wieder auf
ein neuer Tag im Paradies es ist 6 Uhr
morgens um 7 Uhr macht der Schreiner auf
und nutzen wir die Zeit um mal ganz kurz
in den Postkasten zu schauen und zu
sehen dass wir die basistasche ja drin
haben und wir uns Geld dazu verdienen
wollen während die Feldfrüchte wachsen
komm Eleanor und mich in der Strandhütte
besuchen haben die perfekten Willkommens
Geschenke okay strandhüte wir haben eine
neue Quest samengießen ist noch mal
nicht hochgegangen ich probi es noch mal
mit der Gießkanne es ist aber schon ein
bisschen gewachsen hier glaube ich
gießkanner
jetzt es klappt wahrscheinlich hat's im
Regen nicht geklappt ach Gott hier nicht
drauftreten Luca
oder darf
ich okay das ist nicht wie bei Minecraft
ich kann ruhig auf die Farm treten und
das haben wir wir haben die erste Ernte
eingebracht Besuche Sams
Gemischtwarenladen und da müssen wir
dann neue Feldfrüchte anbauen okay okay
wir haben anscheinend immer was zu tun
kaufe ich neue Samen bei Sam gehe ich zu
den Jungs in die Strandhütte und hol mir
neue Gegenstände ab oder suche ich den
Schreiner der in 10 Minuten aufmt oder
mache ich meine Farm weiter und gieß
hier weiter rum ich habe einiges zu tun
es ist aber 47 das heißt wir laufen ganz
fix mal eben rüber zum Schreiner die
drei Sachen möchte ich heute auf jeden
Fall noch erledigt haben nehmen
natürlich hier vorne die Abkürzung über
den moin oh moin der Hahn lachkick ey
der Fasan bestermann oder ein
V mit den kann ich nicht interagieren
kann ich auch nicht
rüberlufen bin ich einfach zu schwach
für guck mal lässt sich gar nicht
beirren der
Ver okay ich gehe schon das W lache KCK
das wäre so geil wenn wir uns irgendwann
so eine hühnerfar machen können dann
haben wir mal Eier dann können wir uns
morgenens so ein Spiegelei braten
vielleicht können wir noch eine Küche
bauen weiß es nicht es ist auf jeden
Fall sehr viel mehr sage ich mal
hinsichtlich sag mal hat sie nicht
vorhin gesagt die Öffnungszeiten sind 7
bis 17 Uhr jetzt steht hier 9 bis 20 Uhr
komm die 20 Minuten die gebe ich euch es
ist 9 Uhr das heißt der Schreiner hat
geöffnet wir können reingehen an die
Öffnungszeiten halten Sie sich auf jeden
Fall und können jetzt direkt sagen ich
würde gerne mein Haus reparieren
Einkaufen Schreiner
hausaufwertung wir schauen mal wir gehen
erstmal zu Schreiner Hühnerstall Scheune
Stall fischteig wir können ja halt alles
mögliche uns irgendwie gönnen ne eine
schune
Hühnerstall oh mein Gott das habe ich
doch gesagt dafür brauchen wir nur noch
Holz 25 Steine und F bronzebarren wie
kriege ich denn jetzt Bronze Minecraft
bringt das nichts aber hier brauche ich
das für ein Hühnerstall klicken wir mal
auf einkaufen und sehen dass wir hier
auch Sachen kaufen können guck mal wir
können dann Geld wir haben 300 übrigens
vom Start wir können für fün können wir
uns ein Stein kaufen für 10 Holz wir
können uns Kalender
kaufen
Aquarium oder ein großes Aquarium boah
wie geil stell mal vor wir machen unser
Haus wie Monte Streaming room mit so
fetten Aquarium ne aber so generell ich
sehe schon so dass wir sehr viel mit
Tieren machen so ein hühnerstein mit zu
Hühnern vielleicht auch irgendwas noch
mit Schweinchen dann drin so ein
Aquarium vielleicht un noch ein Hund
aber wir müssen glaub ich auf die
hausaufwertung klicken wir haben ja 50
Holz und 20 Steine klicken einfach mal
auf Bestätigen nee ach guck
mal wir können zwischen fünf
verschiedenen Stilen wählen boah der ist
schon das wäre so das ehste was ich
nehmen würde weil es so ein bisschen
moderner ist und wir ein bisschen mehr
Glas und demententsprechend Tageslicht
drinnen haben aber das passt am meisten
ne also das hier ist tot das brauchen
wir auf gar keinen Fall das finde ich
auch Quatsch weil mit den Stein hier da
war ich nie ein Fan von das sieht halt
aus wie so eine hexenhütte das ist zu
modern ich glaub das passt nicht da rein
und hier haben wir Sel 5 wisst ihr was
ihr dürft entscheiden ich beende an der
Stelle den ersten Part Coral Island mit
Luca ich habe richtig Bock auf dieses
Projekt wir werden das jetzt mal immer
mal so ab und zu ein bisschen spielen
werden etwas längere Parts se ich hoffe
ihr habt auch Bock drauf schreibt mir
mal in die Kommentare wenn ihr jetzt
noch dran seid welchen Ziel ich nehmen
soll also ich ich würd ich würde den
ersten und zweiten rauslassen dritten
finde ich cool vierten okay kann man
nehmen passt aber vielleicht nicht so
ins Gesamtbild oder das fünfte fünfte
ist schon cool ne mit der Palme und so
aber das ist auch
cool das passt halt irgendwie mehr hier
rein schreibt un in die Kommentare danke
fürs zuschauen ich hoffe es gefällt Euch
wir sehen uns die Tage wieder bei einem
neuen Video wieder haut rein Ciao ich
habe so Bock auf dieses Projekt